ja und bild hat wieder für sie gekämpft
liebe zu schauen und zu schwer und damit
kommen wir jetzt zu einem thema das
wirklich beeindruckend ist alexander h
lauf hat ganze 180 kilo abgenommen nur
die krankenkasse die hat das nicht so
sehr beeindruckt wir schauen einmal auf
die geschichte von herrn harnos
es ist eine fast magische typveränderung
alexander harloff aus fürth verliert
nach einem magenbypass fast 180 kilo
gewicht ein unglaublicher diäterfolg für
den 33-jährigen der jedoch auch spuren
hinterlässt harloff kämpfte seit dem
gewichtsverlust mit überschüssige haut
nur für die 20.000 euro teure op zur
entfernung der hautlappen kommt die
krankenkasse nicht auf alexander hleb
scheitert immer wieder an der
krankenkasse schickt bild dann eine
videobotschaft
man kann es vielleicht hier sehen also
die diese hautlappen hängen praktisch
runter und steuern anstreifen an nähten
ja und die krankenkasse hat mir
daraufhin gar bundes sie werden diesen
diesen antrag noch einmal prüfen
daraufhin habe ich einen komplett neuen
antrag stellen müssen der eigentlich
schon mal genehmigt worden ist
dieser wurde mir aber abgelehnt mit der
begründung dass es eben nicht
medizinisch notwendig ist das team von
bild kämpft für sie entscheidet sich für
harloff einzusetzen macht bei der
krankenkasse druck dann der erfolg die
kasse übernimmt die kosten für den
eingriff bild überraschung in berlin ich
bin hier um ihnen mitzuteilen dass
professor doktor sinus sich dazu bereit
erklärt hat sie morgen schon zu
operieren und zwar kostenlos was sagen
sie dazu
das ist super für mich dann die op nach
fünfeinhalb stunden ist alles
überstanden was für eine erleichterung
[Musik]
news meine damen und herren wir schauen
nach dresden denn dort ist in diesem
moment und das sind live-bilder
die maschine der bundeswehr eingetroffen
der buffo der luftwaffe der airbus 400m
und unser reporter michael deutschmann
ist dort im bild man sie denn ich weiß
nicht ob er uns auch hören kann wenn ja
kann er uns mal ein zeichen geben er
beobachtet wie die maschine gelandet ist
die intensivpatienten corona patienten
cupid patienten aus fliegen soll weil
die situation in dresden zu dramatisch
geworden ist die intensivstation zu
belegt sind deshalb müssen intensiv
patienten ausgeflogen werden von dort in
andere krankenhäuser verlegt werden wer
morgen ist schon mit michael deutschmann
gesprochen und werden auch später noch
mal versuchen zu ihm hin zu schalten
kommen jetzt zurück ins studio michael
steht da im bilde wir werden ihn gleich
noch sprechen denn wir wollen unseren
gast begrüßen alexander hahn auf den wir
vorhin in dem film gesehen haben der
mann der uns wirklich sehr beeindruckt
hat der 180 kilogramm abgenommen hat und
jetzt frisch nach der op hier bei uns im
studio ist hallo hallo können sie diese
live ist das ein ganz neues lebensgefühl
jetzt nach der operation oder wie geht
es ihnen erst mal ja natürlich ist es
ein neues lebensgefühl für mich allein
schon dass mir die angst genommen wird
das irgendwann durch diese extrem
entzündungen der haut eventuell sogar
meinen arbeitsplatz verliert er mich
bedeutet ich bin alleinverdiener ich
habe zwei kinder eines davon schwer
beschädigt und ich brauche unbedingt
meiner arbeit ja und es ist ein
argumentationspapier
einträchtig bin dann ist es für mich
dass das alles medizinisch begründet ist
war alles was einen körper nicht
einschränkt hat für mich immer in
medizinischen hintergrund und deswegen
bin ich sehr dankbar für diese chance
die sich der mir ergeben hat und
natürlich riesig glücklich
wie ist das ein 180 kilo abzunehmen auch
wenn eine operation dabei geholfen hat
natürlich also dass er trotzdem enorme
körperliche anstrengung auch wir müssen
uns das vorstellen ja körperlich ist es
eigentlich muss ich sagen bis auf auf
den hintergrund der sender mehr so viel
essen können durch die operation gar
nicht so ausschlaggebend ich denke eher
dass der psychologische aspekt sehr viel
tiefgreifender ist aufgrund dessen weil
sie sicherlich seelisch oder oder
menschlich verändern sondern nur
körperlich ja also gerade bei mir ich
war um die 18 jahre alt als ich diese
operation gemacht habe und von heute auf
morgen werden sie in der gesellschaft
ganz anders aufgenommen ja sie waren
vorher immer der außenseiter
ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen wir wurden
früchte nach meer geschmissen tomaten
mehr weil man halt einfach anders ist
als andere menschen und dann nehmen die
therapie abpassen wieder in dieses
gesellschaftliche bild hinein und sind
plötzlich mittendrin statt nur dabei ja
also das ist es ist schwer zu verkraften
weil sie sind ja gar nicht anders im
endeffekt sie schauen zwar eine spiegel
und sehen einen anderen körper aber
menschlich gesehen sind sie immer noch
die selbe person mit denselben gefühlen
mit denselben hintergründen alles was
sie erlebt haben das projekt trotzdem
und das ist das traurige wir sind
traurig und trotzdem natürlich eine
verbesserte situation logischerweise für
sie jetzt wir wollen mit dem mann
sprechen der sie operiert hat der diese
kooperation die die krankenkasse
zunächst nicht bezahlen wollte und dann
mit hilfe von bild am ende doch bezahlt
hat mit ihm wollen wir sprechen mit
professor doktor seines hallo herr sie
ließ
guten morgen wie wichtig ist so ein
eingriff für einen patienten
das ist ein teil einer veränderung einer
metamorphose die sie vergleichen können
mit einem schmetterling und also der
raupe die sich in so ein kokon hielt
also es ist tatsächlich so der letzte
schritt wenn dieser diese raupe aus
diesem kokon heraus schlüpft und auf
einmal schmetterling ist und der patient
hat ja alles so doch sehr eindrücklich
wiedergegeben es ist ein völlig neues
leben und dazu tragen wir bei und ist
natürlich schöne an meinem job und in
meinem beruf dass ich den patienten da
helfen kann begleiten können hier war ja
eben dann auf das große problem dass die
krankenkasse nicht zahlen wollte warum
ist das so warum ist das in vielen
fällen so
ich mache den job seit 21 jahren ja und
der verlauf dieses patienten ist sehr
beeindruckend da so viel gewicht zu
verlieren da sehen sie nicht so häufig
ja die krankenkassen finden sich heute
in einer situation wo die kassen
zumindest von der kommunikation heer
weitgehend leer sind und die
kassenleistungen sehr sehr restriktiv
gehalten wir sehen verläufe und auch
entscheidungen der krankenkassen die wir
nicht nachvollziehen können und wie weit
es tatsächlich am ende des tages ist
dass sie an eine eine situation finden
über diesen patienten wo sie 180 kilo im
gesamtverlauf sehen die er verloren hat
und die krankenkasse entscheidet sich
gegen die kostenübernahme das können sie
nicht wirklich rational nachempfinden
herr professor sie ist kurz das wort
noch an ihren patienten wenn sie wollen
also ich freue mich dass wir gemeinsam
mit bild jetzt diesen fall operieren
konnten und ich wünsche ihr von mir aus
ich habe ihn jetzt heute morgen nicht
gesehen weil ich schon im op stand also
zum interview zu ihnen gekommen ich
wünsche von meiner seite alles alles
gute wir sind sowieso jetzt nochmal zu
den nachkontrollen terminen und ich
wünsche ihm tatsächlich von ganzem
ganzem herzen dass er diese chance wir
jetzt einmal bekommen hat
nutzt und und dass er sein neues leben
tatsächlich mit vollen zügen genießt ja
diese stelle mich natürlich auch mal
ganz herzlich bedanken ein doktor das
ist eine einmalige chance die medaillen
geben wurde mit von einem fantastischen
arzt ja also bei hochachtungsvoll vielen
herzlichen dank und ich hoffe wir sehen
uns ganz ganz bald wieder
dankeschön ebenso ein schönes
schlusswort
nach einer erfolgreichen bild kämpft
aktionen vielen dank rossinis vielen
dank hallo für den besuch hier bei uns
im studio